today i'm going to be speaking with greg
barrack who's the author of criminology
on trump and also emeritus professor of
criminology and criminal justice at
eastern michigan university it's really
great having you on i appreciate your
time today
thank you
so in the book you you really do an
analysis of trump and the trump family
and the presidency and the business
enterprise trump uh through through sort
of a criminology lens the idea of trump
operating as a sort of pseudo mob boss
in a sense
can you first lay out the kind of
general approach and perspective that
you used here and what and why you did
it in this way
okay well i'm a criminologist and i
study crime and i study the
administration of justice and i do so
in a very broad
based manner in the sense that i examine
all laws whether they be civil or
criminal uh constitutional international
so
uh he he was a perfect subject a perfect
object and and
what
what i think makes my analysis unique or
different from literally the thousands
of other books on trump
is that it is really
uh
the first and only criminal biography of
donald trump uh and it tries to give the
45th president his rightful place in the
history of u.s crime
um
what it attempts to explain
um
systemically or systematically
throughout his entire life is his
uncanny ability
to get over
of whether we're talking business
economics whether we're talking politics
whether we're talking interpersonal
relationships he has the ability to harm
and abuse and to always escape the
consequences or or almost always
escape at least criminally he's fully
escaped civilly he's been held
accountable more than once so let's
let's talk about a few examples before
he was president trump would notoriously
sue lots of people and the outcomes of
those lawsuits varied pretty
dramatically and in some cases it seemed
as though the lawsuit may have been a
tool to to maybe cover up
his own pre-existing wrongdoing can you
talk a little bit about the use of
lawsuits
right um
well
as
many of your readers may know or many of
your listeners may know
trump's mentor and surrogate father
um
was
jesus how am i having a blank here um
all time
the mccarthy hearings prosecutor okay
uh whose name i also don't remember
right how is this crazy
um you know where's my roy cohn roe
marcus roy marcus cohn yeah right right
okay so so cohn is his his first um
mentor and surrogate father and really
teaches him the art of weaponizing the
law
and the two of them over a case
involving um
housing discrimination in projects owned
by his father throughout new york
um
donald retained uh cohn to represent
them and this is where it all began for
donald to use the law against the law
and to always counter sue to never
acknowledge um defeat
so
that's where it first began and whether
he wins or loses the case it almost is
almost as immaterial to donald
uh because at the end of the day he will
always claim
victory
that he won just as he won the election
he knows he didn't win the election he
knows he didn't win the cases that he
claims to but
that's his narrative can you talk about
other sometimes the the term is used
that
he had a way to skirt the law in his
business career which is skirting the
law different than breaking the law
um
i i you know i can't tell you
you know that there's any legal
meaning to the notion of skirting
the the law it's right evading the law
it's like not getting caught
it's not really
not breaking the law he he's he's you
know engaged in lawlessness pretty much
day in and day out through various types
of business arrangements uh that he's he
he's put put together
um
what are some examples of that
well
the best example is the way in which
beginning with uh
uh fred senior uh
donald donald's father
that he began to transfer his enormous
wealth
to his children
um some of which you could
legitimately pass on and some of which
he um created shell companies that were
companies in name only he created
arrangements where
[Music]
donald and his siblings
became owners of certain companies
within the trump organization and so he
was billing them for work that he wasn't
doing
uh that that's an example donald has
continued with with that into
uh with uh at least three of his
children that were aware of uh eric and
and junior and ivanka
when we think about the trump presidency
he's really gotten away
with the most kind of basic pedestrian
just kind of shrugging off the things
that are thrown at him i mean he
recently had four cell phones subpoenaed
and he wrote i lost the phones i don't
know where the phones are well what's
going to come of that we don't know
probably probably nothing uh endless
requests for documents that seem to be
legitimate requests subpoenas etc no
here it's executive privilege and there
it's a political witch hunt and it seems
as though he just gets away with it is
that in fact the way that it has gone
um
criminally
that is in fact the way it has gone i
mean he's yet to be prosecuted for a
single
criminal offense yes in his life so it's
certainly gone that way there in terms
of his civil litigation he has a an
impressive record maybe he's lost 40 50
cases one hundred the rest have been
draws
and when you say a draw
is that good for trump or good for
someone else
um it's usually good for trump okay
because you know trump has a
an interesting habit when he wins the
case
you and i the taxpayers pay his
attorneys and when he loses a case he
stiffs his attorneys right right when it
comes to the current investigations you
know i have people in my audience who
are convinced i mean convinced
that at some point trump's going to face
criminal prosecution i just don't think
so and when we go through what's being
looked at right now
there's the january 6th committee who
could make referrals depending on what
they find to the justice system they
could although it's not their main
charge as as described there's the new
york investigation where we actually saw
some investigators resign because they
got the impression that there's not
really any interest in actually
prosecuting donald trump you've got the
georgia investigation for possible
election fraud i mean is there any shot
any of this stuff goes anywhere
um
yeah there's always there's always a
shot that goes somewhere i i think
that what
people want to know is whether
uh attorney general emerit garland
whether or not he's going to
come come forward and you know people
have been very
wishy-washy and you know wanting this to
have occurred already
what i think is significant a couple of
things i think are significant as to why
i think he ultimately will oh
prosecute i mean i've been very
you know
you know i've been mixed as to whether
he will or he won't uh in part one sign
was uh
uh eric uh former attorney general
uh eric holden mike
holder thank you eric holder who is an
institutionalist who for example didn't
prosecute the 10 000 uh security
fraudsters on wall street gave them all
a pass
he thought that in all likelihood
because
presidents in the past have been given
passes by
the next attorney general that this
would be the same situation with with
trump he's
come around and thinks differently now
that we understand that this was
involving significant number of elected
and appointed officials and how big the
conspiracy was
um
he now thinks that you know there should
be a prosecution his change in position
is significant but i think last but not
least because of the historical
situation that we find ourselves in in
terms of autocrats and democrats and
struggles in with ukraine and russia and
elsewhere that
it becomes
rather embarrassing and it becomes a
slap in the face of so-called american
democracy when we prove that somebody
and somebodies who have power are above
the law it's not a very good marketing
tool for the united states and i think
that political pressure because it's on
the world stage
is also adding
uh substance to the fact that i think
garland is going to go after him how how
long could it take before he
prosecutes yeah
um
in my mind
it could it could go as long as before
the primary
of um 2024.
okay i mean the problem is
if they go after him
and if he can keep
the delays
from the actual trial
occurring before the primary begins then
he'll be able to probably sidestep
whether he wins or loses 20 24 because
i'm convinced that whether he loses or
not he they will the republicans and
company will actually steal the election
so therefore he can keep
the
attorney general
and the justice department away from him
to 2029. wait so i don't want to go i
don't want to miss something you just
said that's a big deal
you believe that in 24
the the sort of trial run that was 2020
some of those different ideas that were
floated for how to take an election they
didn't win you think they might
successfully use those tools in 24
i think they're well on their way they
have control
of
26 out of the 50 state
legislative bodies who could and are in
fact
preparing themselves
to overturn the election
wow
um okay let's come back to that
uh
the um
many
armchair mental health professionals
during the trump era
would maybe not diagnose but suggest
that donald trump
could be
narcissistic
that he might be delusional that he's
self-deluded that he's mentally ill in
different ways that he lies
uncontrollably pathological lies etc one
of the things that you write if i
understand it correctly is that while
all of those things may be true
you don't believe that any of it is the
sort of explanation or ultimate cause of
the criminality and the lying and the
deception that in that sense he knows
what he's doing am i am i accurately
summarizing your position you are spot
on that's exactly what we are arguing he
is a rational player he may be
you know suffering from a variety of
mental illnesses but when it comes to
his day-to-day affairs he is a rational
player he clearly knows that he did not
win the election he is not self
um deluded for a moment he's a con a
performance artist and he's just doing
the script so how do you know that and i
guess with like the election thing is an
example i've gone back and forth over
time does trump think he won the
election or does he know that it's that
he didn't really win
and i was kind of on the side of he's
lying it's a con
but more recently we've had reports from
behind the scenes that he was privately
talking to people and saying that he won
which doesn't sound like something he
would do if he knew he didn't really win
it depends on who he's probably talking
to okay
he wouldn't say that to jared he
wouldn't say it to ivanka but he would
say it to
um
the people who have all been subpoenaed
for example like mark meadows for
example he would keep up the lie with
mark meadows he would keep up the lie
with those people i mean jared knows
better
um you know he he knows a lot you know
it wasn't stolen just like bannon knows
it wasn't stolen
so then you're so so you're
assertion is
when it comes to
the audience that needs to hear the lies
trump knows he's not telling the truth
oh absolutely absolutely that's why he's
such a great performer
um
when it comes to
zooming out a little bit now
sure uh one of the conversations that
took place a bunch of times while trump
was president was
are our checks and balances sort of like
robust enough
and
one of the kind of answers that was
zeroed in on was
generally speaking they are but the
founding fathers never imagined
someone like trump would be elected and
that's why
there aren't more checks and balances
that would have prevented some of the
things that donald trump did what what's
your sense of that did the checks and
balances
fail um i'm not sure the checks and
balances um were were
were tested until now right
you know so so and they clearly
it remains to be seen whether or not
they work
or they don't work from my perspective
with respect to the
the popular
story or
explanation that the founding fathers
never thought that an oligarch or that
some you know a
very wealthy person could be doing
similar things to donald um
i they knew about kings i mean they knew
about the danger of of of the parties
reverting back you know they didn't care
for parties but yeah so i i don't buy
that but you know i'm i'm
not
that much of an expert to know fair fair
the book is criminology on trump we've
been speaking with the book's author
greg barrack who's also emeritus
professor of criminology and criminal
justice at eastern michigan university
uh so appreciate your time today thank
you so much
thank you david